ｽﾁｬｯ
（ガムうめぇ...）
俺かっけぇ...
ｶﾞｺｶﾞｺｶﾞｺ
（ﾄﾞﾔｧ...）
↗のぶこ
ﾁﾗｯ
（あ どうもー）
（どうぞ渡ってくだせぇ）
ｸｯﾁｬｸｯﾁｬｸｯﾁｬｸｯﾁｬｸｯﾁｬ
アデュー！
よいしょっ
見ててほら あの ソードアートオンラインの
アスナとキリトのまね
はい！おはようございます はじめしゃちょーでーす
ちょっと のぶこを外に連れ出して、
公園に配置してみました
で この今いる公園なんですけども
結構ね おじいちゃんとかおばあちゃんが多くて
休日の日曜でも結構人が通るんですよ
で この日常的な 公園という空間の中に
非日常的な 異生物
ｴｧﾘｪｧﾝ
のぶこがもしこの日常的な公園の生活の中にいるとしたら
おじいちゃん
おばあちゃん
子供たち
わかんない いろんな人がいると思います
のぶこを見たらどういう反応をするのか
検証していこうと思います
ふつーに公園にエイリアンがいますからね今
この公園の人たちは
のぶこを受け入れるのか
それとも 受け入れられないのか
今後のエイリアンとの友好関係に関わってくる実験です
見ていきましょう！
ちなみに
許可とってます！
さすがにエイリアンここに置くことはちょっと怖かったんで
一応許可をとってあります
（まぶしい...）
暇だな...
やっばい暇だなー
あっ！すげっ！いいな！
走り込みの中学生たちがいます
部活で頑張ってる子たちが
ひょっとしたらエイリアンに
くいつくかもしれない
だれかっ！
無反応かっ！
無反応ってあるか！
いやいや、みんな！
エイリアンだぞ
嘘じゃん…
まじめかよ…
えっ、えっ、えっ？
あっ…
こんだけ…走り込みの
学生がいるのに
一人も見向きもしないっていう
いやいや、みんなエイリアンだよ？
フッ( ´ー)ﾉ
カワイイ～
エイリアンには…
すいません  なんかちょっとたぶん
ひとは多いんですけど
設置場所が悪かったのかな…？
人が来なくて、ハトばっかり来ちゃうんで
ちょっと、のぶこの場所を変えてみます
おっ、おっおおお、
えっ、えっ！
何が起きてる？
写真撮ってる？
さぁ～、気になりつつ
コンビニで買った袋を開けてます
みんな、そんな、なんか…
ねっ？リアクションしない…ねっ？
ハッ(笑)
チラッチラッと見てるんだよね
おっ、おっ、おおおおお
ハッ、はっ
やっ
ヤバいっ！
未知との遭遇すぎて
ほらっ！もう
足を止めました×２
チャリで、近づくが…
これは？
ど、どっ　えっ何してる？
触ってる？
ファーストコンタクトです
ちょっと、距離をとちゃったか
ガン見して…
行ってしまいました
おっ だが
立ち止まるが…行ってしまう
おっ！
お お おお
おっ
気づいた？
近くに寄りにいっても…
スルーする
おっ、お お？おぉ？
なんか、イッキに！
イッキになんか…
かわいそすぎ…
おっ!
止まりましたよ！
さぁ、見つめ合う
見つめ合って、足を止める
振り返る！
逆から振り返って、逆側に歩き出す
スルー。
おしいな、
いいせんまで行ってんだけどな…
もういっこ踏み込んで
座って頂けると…
あー、だめかー
近づく！
接触！
接触してる！接触しました！
接触していますが…
お母さんの警戒心が高そうですね
赤ちゃんが
あんまり…
好きじゃなさそうですね
がんスルー
おぉ
あああ
のぶこのヒザが…
いじくりまわされてる
膝小僧、超いじられてんじゃん
あぁ～、もうお気に入りじゃん
超気に入っちゃったんじゃん
ついに座った？
のぶこが…
子供に受け入れられたね
バイバイかな？
バイバイだね